is intimately connected to the religion
of Islam it appeared within that
religion although we can certainly argue
for outside influence impacting its
Origins too and the two have until
recently always been looked at in tandem
with each other
in fact for most of History it would
have been inconceivable to view Sufism
as its own category which would have
been compared to Islam it was Islam or
at the very least an aspect of that
religion neither should it be considered
a branch of Islam I see many people talk
about Sufi alongside Sunni and Shia as
branches of the religion but this is
very inaccurate
Sufism should rather be seen as a kind
of aspect or science within Islam
similar and alongside other aspects like
theology or thick Islamic law